the initial seed for the film was really
my research into real cases of mass
psychogenic illness and hysterics
throughout history and kind of looking
at patterns and starting to think about
reimagining those kind of subconscious
movements as choreographies of sorts and
then I brought on my producer early
secure off who's also a co-writer and my
editor Celia Davis as a co-writer I had
never written in narrative screenplay so
the idea of making it a really
collaborative process where we could
talk it out and put in the room and
including kind of varied voices I think
was helpful from phase 1 yeah did you
ever during the process like think about
defining exactly what is happening or
without always that kind of the
ambiguity the ambiguity of it always
part of what the story would be yeah i
think in real cases that we looked at
they seemed to remain a mystery and i
definitely think that our film takes a
leap towards the allegorical so in kind
of keeping both with the historical
cases and where we were hoping move on
to keep it open but there was definitely
a push and pull between is this a story
about Tony or is this a story about
these episodes and the writing
breakthrough really came through the
decision to make it very singular in its
vantage point and every you know the
fits filtered through Tony's perspective
helped open it up I think and how did
you communicate that with the actors in
terms of like what you wanted them to
think about it or all that yeah so
actually the original see for this film
did not take place with drill or in
Cincinnati that came through our casting
process so we actually really wanted to
cast all the girls in the film from the
same dance team so everyone you see in
our film dances together including
royalty hurt our our lead and so we
started to collaborate with them as
authors in the process we really wrote
for that location and a lot of things
needed to be adapted but i think the
core of the film remain the same and
they rewrote their own
log and so we really workshop the script
for about six weeks before we started
filming and that was about
comfortability and i think kind of just
strengthening it and our processes
filmmakers was really to to be open open
book and allow the kids to really take
ownership of what we were doing together
yeah how did you find royalty as the
lead Tony in the film so we opened up
girl casting only to the q-kidz there's
a couple hundred of them in real life we
cast 45 in our film royalty was the
eighth girl that read so I had heard a
lot quite a few horror stories about kid
casting which was not our experience it
was just kind of incredible I originally
imagined that we would cast someone
older who looks younger royalty was nine
the day that she read but I think it
helped because Alexis who plays BZ was
also night and they had a really great
energy and they were the two actors that
really excited me the most and I deeply
just wanted to work with them as people
and they're both very like royalty is so
engaged with herself which is a
requirement anything for Tony but she's
just able to reflect back to you on her
face and do a lot with listening yeah I
mean that's one of the most interesting
as a film is that there isn't a ton of
dialogue and there was a lot of reliance
on their performances to carry the story
and what's going on yeah we we talked a
lot about movement so we also worked so
we work with three choreographers to
drill kroger choreographers Mariah Jones
or identical twins they're incredible
and then we also worked with as a modern
dancer as a movement consultant and we
really approached every scene through
movement because these are trained
dancers they compete nationally their
elite artists and performers so every
emotional thing that we were working
with we talked about movement how do you
hold your shoulders when are you
breathing what's your is your core
engaged when and so that's how we broke
things down and with royalty in
particular
she's a very physical performer so which
is why she's great for Tony but and she
actually crossed out quite a few of her
lines during the script process she's
like redundant actions already saying
enough so yeah she's a great
collaborator and how about the UM I
wanted am curious by the interaction
with the scenes with the boxing because
it's also very very choreograph yeah
they're also Deshawn minor plays
Jermaine's ranked number three in the
country he's a junior Olympian so these
are like elite athletes who were
gracious and generous with me with their
time while they were like competing for
her titles so yeah we really wanted
royalty had to train to box she trained
for about three weeks and a lot of that
was with Dashon as kind of bonding but
it's very choreographed I think the
qualities that make you a great boxer
translate seamlessly into dance there's
a different energy with boxing than with
the answer but yeah I think we tried we
approach that as a dance film as well
and this was part of a process that
Venice bunnell benally had sorry cinema
college words a micro-budget okay can I
ask is a really bad Q and a question but
like what does that mean in terms of
this was what is a micro-budget what was
the budget for the film yeah well it's
very public so the Menace Biennale has
an initiative and you know the Venice
Biennale is one of the oldest art
institutions in the world they fund many
art disciplines cinemas their newest art
so officially cinemas art for three
years and they have a it's not only a
micro-budget they give you a grant of
150 thousand euros but they also require
you to make the film in under a year so
for us budgetary constraints are one
element of limitations time actually was
much more challenging for us because
often when you're working in a
micro-budget scale you take your time
and you hustle and you do jobs on the
side and we weren't allowed that kind of
privilege in this case and so it really
became everyone like all hands on deck
but there was this other currency
because we were going to be premiering
at
and that actually really affected the
attitude on set I think oftentimes in
the American indie space you work and
you work in your work and you actually
never know if what you're doing will
ever be seen by anybody and that's
really hard to work in that space and to
rally every day being like it could be
great and nobody sees that that happens
every day in our industry so I think
knowing that it was going to premiere at
Venice was a huge motivating factor for
our team and after the constraints I
think made us make bolder choices and
really examine what was necessary and
and focus on those lean kind of crucial
elements and your shoot was 30 days 19
with a a 16 days it was all in 72 minute
features yeah it was all in Cincinnati
yeah we shot we shot almost exclusively
in a single location what you see on
screen is one building in the rec center
community center where the q-kidz
actually practice and yeah we we did a
couple extra pickup days after we had a
fine cut of the film some some close-ups
and and a few little moments and yes so
I think it added up to like 22 total and
cut a special summit Agra for Paul Yi
who was so instrumental and although
just a great look of the film and just
that yeah Paul is incredible one of my
oldest friends he's a gaffer by trade
and and he's been shooting he's actually
shot almost everything I've got
redirected so we have a great kind of
easy language that is also founded in
challenging each other in a really
positive way but he came on before we
had a full draft of the script which i
think is very rare dedication from a DP
and his philosophy you know we look up
to a lot of DPS like gastrula men dress
or who kind of showcase kind of
functionality as elegance and he came on
for two weeks before start shooting made
some charts for every single room but
really our conversations centered around
placing the audience expiry
in tony's body and vantage point and
what POV meant because sometimes POV is
seeing what she sees but most often POV
is watching her watch and kind of
setting these rules for ourselves being
very sensitive to dance and highlighting
dance in its conventional and and kind
of abstract with forms in the film I
have it's a lot of interesting choices
like they're they're very few adults in
the film there's no home the homes and I
was wondering how much of that came out
I don't know if it's answerable in this
way but like how much of it came out of
what you would you wanted to achieve
before you came on to set and how much
was afterwards or just knowing your
limitations yeah we was always our focus
to kind of keep it in the kids world
because we felt like once you introduce
adults particularly legs and charisma
skerrick ters lose power they need to be
the top of the pyramid and adults coming
in kind of take that power away from
them but also those memories that I have
of that time adults are kind of blurry
and in the like part of the lens that
doesn't register focus no matter how far
they are but yeah the that's what my
memories feel like so kind of being true
to that we tried actually more extreme
versions where adults didn't exist in
the world and that felt in authentic to
what we were trying to say and so yeah
but we also really our philosophy was
that this these few moments after school
before you go home become so formative
and yeah so like the overpass is
essentially her bedroom if it were
another script those scenes would be her
alone in her room you know kind of
rocking out to her record player like
that's what's happening but it's it's in
the overpass and like the laundry room
kind of becomes their living room and
like so we thought about how each of the
spaces functioned emotionally in and if
we were in kind of a more traditional
narrator script what would those places
be but yeah and how about the music it's
so distinctive how did you choose the
music how did you discover it so the
original score is by Danny benzion
sonner durians
who was just a gift to collaborate with
them the idea for pretty much all of my
collaboration started with talking about
breath and the score really we focused
on the instrument as a body and being
able to hear breath go through it and
also allowing the audience to know that
something was off before the fits enter
into the narrative so the first time you
hear music is really like something is
brewing something something irreversible
is beginning to change with Tony and
allowing the score to be her voice and
the other two music choices that we
sampled we really wanted like music that
these girls would dance to so the rye
rye Tyga came out of searching for that
and then the end song we actually shot
the end sequence to a different song so
we were locked into a very specific time
signature and our assistant editor
brought that song to us and it's just
one of those things where you're
grateful that filmmaking collaborative
art and other people are bringing you
ideas that are better than anything you
could have found on your own well I want
to thank you for for being here and
thank that thing thank you guys so much
thank you
[Applause]